steve long time no talk to you last time
we talked
nestor was sitting next to me but now
it's just you and me you have a very
good memory
of course i do
yeah i remember the yeah hotel
yeah i remember exactly very crowded
hallway very crowded but um no longer
because we're being coveted safe so i'm
so glad to see you today even from a
distance
right back at you um i've seen all of
season two i want to say it is uh
fantastic oh god yeah yeah i'm glad you
like it you don't you don't have to
worry it's it's so good
i have so many questions but before i
jump into those questions um i really
want to know how which of your friends
and family were the most excited uh when
you signed on to do this sex in the city
series
wow
i mean hands down everybody was so
thrilled to hear that the show is so
iconic there's a bunch of really great
women on the show great female actresses
uh female actors and they're like how
did you go from these awesome female
actors on this drama to these awesome
female actors on this comedy like we
don't get it and um there are a bunch of
people that work hard to make it happen
but
yeah i feel pretty fortunate it's pretty
awesome
uh i know i know you can't say much but
can you tease anything about your
character and your game i can't tease
anything about it but what i will say is
the
the stuff that i loved about sex and the
city remains
in and just like that although some of
the players have changed right there's
still it's still a great story about
love
and friendship and womanhood and
sisterhood and i talked to michael
patrick king about that the show has
always been about love and that remains
so i i really hope people will tune in
it's it's a great story i love my
character she's my favorite one of all
of uh the new characters they're
exploring on the show so
that series always has great clothing i
hope you get to keep what you're wearing
i keep nothing but that's okay
[Laughter]
jumping into why i get to talk to you um
mia
is dealing with a lot in season two yes
and um you know the repercussions of
mitch there's so much going on and uh uh
i guess what can you tease fans about
what are you allowed to say about season
two what i can tell you is
is actually a lot mia becomes the
executive producer of the morning show
after struggling season one to maintain
her reputation and her integrity after
having had a workplace relationship with
mitch kessler right and um but after the
fallout of alex levy and bradley
jackson's huge um
you know reveal of what was going on at
the morning show in uba
um mia
receives the opportunity of being the
executive producer of the morning show
when it is at its worst and so when i
was talking to the producers and writers
about the show
they were saying you know mia's sort of
standing on the proverbial glass cliff
you know
she's got the herculean task of making
the morning show the number one show
again or turning it around and we see
that arc uh
you know unfold over 10 episodes through
the filter of gender and race politics
different personalities what is it like
to lead a news organization through a
transition like that and
so she's tackling it along with corey
ellison and uh stella bach and
you know
it's it's great it's fascinating uh i
hope people tune in
oh yeah if you're a fan of this first
season they're all in uh do you view
corey as a good person a bad person or
it depends on the day of the week
[Laughter]
i i think that
with any network executive you have a
good bit of cynicism you hope for the
best um i i think that i i believe that
mia believes that corey has the best
intentions but he's probably going to do
whatever it takes to get the job done
you i don't want to reveal too much but
i will say that you have a very
emotional scene in season two a specific
scene that i will not talk about but i
am curious as an actor how when you know
you have a scene like that coming up
and say you're filming it on a monday
how much are you breaking down how you
want to do this scene in advance are you
sort of leaving it till sunday and sort
of being like you know what i mean can
you sort of talk about when you're
filming a scene like that you know when
you're filming a scene where it requires
a high level of emotion or
um
a nuance of expression of like anger or
sadness and and humor and and um
and pain just like i did in in episode
seven in season one you try to be as
familiar with the words as you can be so
that when you get on set you're
available to your collaborators and your
creatives to do it in a myriad of ways
so as soon as i got the script i was um
i was filling myself up with whatever i
needed to do to be on set and be
available and i was very lucky to have
um
a great writer like carrie aaron um
writing those monologues and jeff
augustin and
um all the writers in the writers room
but i had an incredible
ally and advocate in victoria mahoney
who directed episode 8 the episodes
you're talking about and um
you know the morning show
the actors and the crew the directors
uh just
the best of the best i mean it's an
extraordinarily
prestigious
you know creative environment and you
want to bring your best and
and so um you know thanks for saying
that i try to rise to the occasion when
i get the opportunity to really convey a
dramatic moment for for our audience
yeah i know it's a great scene which i
will not
i mean i ca i would love to talk more
but uh so we can later on steve i'm
around
[Laughter]
i might be following up um i love
learning about the behind the scenes of
the making of of anything right and um
i'm sure what do you think might
surprise fans of the show to learn about
like the behind the scenes of the making
of the show of the morning show or of
any morning television news show oh no
just of making the morning show i should
be specific i would say how much people
care like we actually care about the
stories that we're telling and how the
stories are told um i think probably
that we care less about what audiences
and critics feel about it than what we
feel about in our our sort of insular
circle of what kind of creative um spark
is between us as we are going through
our own individual processes um
probably that the priority for us is
on this set especially season two was
the health and well-being of the people
around us and i think people might be
surprised at how much
care is taken and not just the telling
of the story but in the storytellers
yeah one of the things also is you guys
started filming if i'm not mistaken uh
as right before covet hit and then you
went on that big break and i'm curious
did do you know um how did your
storyline possibly change as a result of
kovan being introduced into the story
you know
i i don't know if it changed all that
much i knew that mia was going to be
promoted to the executive producer job
um
but the ins and outs of how that was
going to translate itself
through season two i didn't know i think
that
the spark of inspiration as our
producers go through it the stories
always kind of shift and change from
from script to script and edit to edit
so you know you leave yourself flexible
as an actor to interpret whatever it is
they they consider to be the priority in
each episode um
but um i think for me during the
hiatus or the pause was
when we decided that we were going to
come back and tell a bit more of the
you know race and race politics after
having
lived through all of the social and
racial racial unrest in the united
states i i really wanted to link arms up
and and tell a really
nuanced um authentic story about what it
looks like to be
uh an african-american woman you know
empowered to do a job but you know
not really knowing how
to get the job done and not sure that
she could do it
with the hostility and the
microaggressions of that of that
experience
you did a great job seriously i know
fans are going to love it thank you so
much for your time and good luck with
the rest of your speed dating oh thank
you